مكاري لبنانيه هاجرت مع عائلتها الى فرنسا
في سن الثلاثه لتصبح لاحقا ناشطه كوميديه
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وذلك بنقد
ثقافتها اللبنانيه التي ورثتها عن امها
واصدقائها اللواتي هن بدورهم هاجرنا الى
فرنسا في ثماننيات القرن الماضي
لاهلي قاعد جنبي الان التقى كارن او كوكو
ماك واعد هذا التقرير اعده
قبل ما نيجي على دبي نتابع
[موسيقى]
معك ابدا بهالموضوع اسمعي هلا من طرف
نسالها السؤال
[موسيقى]
ولم تجد افضل من يوميات شخصيه امراه
لبنانيه تقليديه تعيش في فرنسا الاقتباس
افكار المواضيع التي تطرح على منصاتي
التواصل
[موسيقى]
دخلك الملوخيه اي بهارات بحطولها لانه انا
وانا ابدا ابدا ابدا متفقين على الموضوع
انا من انا وصغيره كل اهلتي بعتوا لي كوكو
اوكي
واسمي مكاري فمكاري عملته بس انا اول ما
فتحت الانستغرام ما فكرت انه هلكو ممكن
يتطور
فكرت فيها وهيك طلعت كوكو مكمك ويوم حاسه
انه منيح ليكي الغنيه اللي عملتيها كانت
كتير لذيذه معك عن جد
[موسيقى]
بس انا بتسمع على العالم شو بيحكوا وبرجع
بعبر على اللي سمعته بالفيديو ممكن احكي
عن كتير ومواضيع ممكن احكي عنه مواضيع
كتير مضحكه لحتى للعالم هيك تضحك وممكن
كمان احكي عن مواضيع عن مشاكل النسوان
اليوم بالبيئه العربيه بطريقه مضحكه بجرب
فوت مساج لحتى لكل العقليات يبلشوا
يتغيروا شوي اسم الله عليك انا ابني ده
رسمه سين هو اكبر حكيم بالعالم هنا شخصيه
ما مع مكمك التي تلتقي صديقتها منى
اللبنانيه الانيقه وهنا تغني كريم اغنيه
عربيه مترجمه الى الفرنسيه
وهنا تنتحل شخصيات اخرى باسلوب عيشهم
بطريقه حرفيه مثلا امرار بكون قاعده تنقول
مع امي وبنكون عم نحكي عن موضوع مثلا تكون
عم تنتقد وحده تزوجت تنقول وجوازها منو
ماشي الحال بتسمع انا عليها شو عم بتقول
فبتركب بالفكره براسي مثلا وبعدين برجع
بعملها بكتبها بقول ماما شو قالت انا شو
بدي ارد عليها رايه يمكن عندها
وبعدين بيلعبوا
[موسيقى]
خلونا نعيش عيشه كلاب احسن
على تحضير مقاطع فيديو تنشر على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي مقاطع هادفه تسلط
الاضواء على مساحات قد تكون ناقده للجاليه
اللبنانيه في فرنسا او المجتمع اللبناني
هناك في بيروت وتعمل ايضا على تحويل ذلك
الى عمل مسرحي يقدم في مدينه الثقافه
والفن باريس
صباح العربيه